سنه عن سنه ودور عن دور بتثبت حنان مطاوع
انها ملكه الادوار الصعبه ووحش تمثيل في
رمضان بتخوت تجربتين مختلفتين الاول مسلسل
سر الباتع مع المخرج خالد يوسف والثاني
اللي تكلمنا عنه هو وعود سخيه بشخصيه سخيه
واللي انتهى عرضه بعد
سخيه شخصيه تتعرض للظلم والقهر وبتتحول من
انسانه طيبه لانسانه اكبر همها الانتقام
تعالي يا قمر احنا اللي بنكهرب الاسعار ما
تعملش فيها مافيا وانت راجل بالعافيه ريح
وك بقى تتكلم عدل
اسم الله
قسما بالله العلي العظيم لاخليهم يتمنوا
الموت وما يلا
قوا والمسلسل على فكره عملت تفاعل كبير
خلال عرضه وبعده والسبب النهايه الماساويه
اللي ما ابغى احرجها للي ما تفرج خلال عرض
المسلسل الناس تفاعلت كثير كمان مع مشاهد
وجمل لسخيه صارت مثل الحكم
وعود سخيه خلص لكن حنان لسه مكمله معنا
رمضان في سر الباتعلم ملحمه التاريخيه
اللي بيخرجها خالد يوسف لاول مره في
الدراما وبتشكل عودته فيها بتلعب دور
صافيه القوي الصلبه الثائر المثابره واللي
بينه وبين السلطان حامد اللي هو احمد صلاح
السعدني علاقه حب كبير
[ضحك]
بحبك يا حامد
كنت لازم تسالوا عن الارض تيجي قبل ما
تيجوا تشوفوا طحنه فيها كم معتدي ودفننا
وان كان في وعود سخيه او سر الباتع مثل
العاده الارشادات بتلاحق حنان مطاوع في اي
عمل
في الاستوديو من بعد طول انتظار النجمه
على المطاوع اهلا فيك يا حنان منورتنا
اليوم اخيرا معانا يا فرحه قلبي والله
مبسوطه جدا احنا دايما كنا نتقابل عن بعد
بالواتساب وبالتليفونات وكده اخيرا عندي
النت وحش قوي في البيت وكنت بعمل مستحيل
علشان اطلع معاكي
طبعا مبروك عملين يعني مهمه جدا يعني بس
مختلفين كمان جدا بتحبي نحكي عن وعود
سخريه اول ولا سر الباتع اول والله
الاثنين ولادي زي ما انت عايزه ههه طب
خلينا نبتدي بوعود سخيه لانه
مختلف مختلف انت انت غيرتي جلدك فيه يعني
او انا كده حسيت هل هذا الانطباع صحيح
عندي ده حقيقي او كانت محاوله مني ان انا
اغير جلدي وكنت فرحانه جدا
بالتفاعل بتاع الناس في الشارع كمان يعني
ما كنتش متخيله خالص ان المسلسل هيتشاف لل
القهاوي تبقى فاتحه والناس تبقى متابعه
وعايزه تعرف كل يوم متشوقه عايزه تعرف
المنصور هيعمل ايه حماده
رجبيه يعني حفظه الاسماء حتى بتاعه
الشخصيات فكنت فرحانه جدا
السخيه هو اسم منتشر وبشكل عام ولا لا
خالص وانا كمان المؤلف اول ما اختاره قلت
له سخيه اكيد هنغيره مش كده يعني جاء
مكتوب باسم سخيف يعني حتى انا لما جات لي
فكره او يعني تركيبه الشخصيه وطلبت انا
عايزه اعمل الشخصيه الفلانيه للاستاذ
المؤلف فهو مشكورا حطها في الفكره بتاعته
دي
فاختار اسم سخريه قلت له ايه سخيه في حد
اسمه سخيه اصلا
بس بعد حلقه او اثنين حسيت انه مثير
للدهشه او للتساؤل اوكي
للاهتمام حسيت انه كده طيب بس المسلسل
كمان يعني برضه من الاعمال اللي هي خلينا
نقول انه قصيره يعني او ما بتستمر طول
الشهر وانت السنه الماضيه كان عندك برده
تجربه نوعا ما مماثله عملتي 15 حلقه
وبعدين رجعتي 15 حلقه الموضوع مختلف تاني
لقيتي هذا الشيء بيناسبك اكثر
لا هي مش حكايه بيناسبني هي كانت ظروف
العمل بتاعت السنه اللي فاتت
عملنا 15 ونزلناهم او يعني طلبنا ان احنا
انا طلبت ان احنا ننزلهم في رمضان
فالحقناهم ب 15 تانيين
السنه دي لضيق الوقت دخلنا ب15 بس الحقيقه
انه ال 15 حلقه بتبقى موجزه جدا بتبقى
بتمنع المشاهد من الملل
بتبقى مشوقه اكتر بالذات لو تم ايجادتها
بتكون كده مترابطه اكتر ايوه طيب انت اللي
يعني يعرفك في الطبيعه بيشوف كيف بتتكلمي
سخيه ما بتتكلم كده
كيف كيف قدرتي تردحي الربح ده صراحه ولا
هو موهبه كامله كانت بالداخله ولقيتيها
فرصه تطلع ولا ايش ايوه نفسي اتخانق ايوه
لا يا حبيبتي انا دايما بحس انه الفنان
جواه ودائما بقولها جواه كاميرا بيرصد
الاخرين وبيصورهم وبيختزلهم جواهم
بيختزن الوديع
والاسي والشرس
والطبقات مختلفه من المجتمع واهم حاجه انك
تبقي حاسه بيهم ما تقدمهمش بشكل قشري او
شكلي ده انت كمان بتبقي مصوراهم من جواهم
بتصوري اوجعهم وافرحهم
وانزلاقهم ونجاحاتهم علشان تقدري تعبري
عنهم بارياح فكل الصور دي موجوده جوايا
بشكل ما يعني النماذج دي انا شفتها بشكل
او باخر من راجل او من ست هي مش لازم
شخصيه بعينها بس كل النماذج دي انا
قابلتهم سواء عن قرب او سواء ملمح كده
خارجي فلما بتجيلي بقى شخصيه بتطلع كل
الشخصيات اللي انا صورتها جوايا وحملتها
جوه قلبي
وبحاول اطلع منها بقى مع جزء تخيلي برضه
هو انت كنت مقنعه زياده عن اللزوم بصراحه
انا
حنان طيب خلينا هنعرض لك الان فيديو كمان
انت نشرتيه خلينا نشوفوه مع بعض ونرجع
نتكلم عنه يلا
علامك وظيفتك قرشك هم سلاحك
اوعي تبكي على واحد مسكرتك اغلى منه
اتفقنا
علامك وظيفتك قرشك هما سلاحك
اوعي تبكي على واحد مسكرتك اغلى منه حصل
من جواك سخيه عايزه تطلع دلوقتي ههه
اه يا حنان
بس الفرصه بتاعتك لو بس تجيني الفرصه دي
انا سخريه بداخلي
جدا
اسوي العجب بس يعني عجبتني دي انه ما تبكي
على واحد تنزل دموع مسكرتك اغلى منه نصائح
دي ايش وضعها
عشان ابقى امينه طبعا هي
البنوته الجميله جدا اللي ماسكاه لي
سوشيال ميديا اقترحت هذا الفيديو لانه
كانت سخيه وقتها
كان تقريبا ده يوم تسع رمضان مش تقريبا او
كانت يعني جايبه قوي مع الناس يعني
عايزين نقول حاجه سخيه ستايل فقلت لها لا
انا ما بعرفش اعمل ده خالص فقلتها وبعدين
اخاف ادي نصيحه ما هو اصل السخيه دي برضه
يعني دماغها مش كويسه خالص يعني موده
البنت الصغننه في حته مش كويسه فقلت لها
انا ما اقدرش برضه يعني
يعني اقول كلمه الكلمه مسؤوليه يعني فقلت
طب هحاول قد ايش عندك كده ضمير حلو
هتكتبي لي اوكي فقلت اوظف اقول كلمه برضو
هاد
وظيفتك ده ده حاجات مش مبتزله وحاجات
حقيقيه ممكن تبقى مبناه بس بادق سخان
فقالت لي لا بس لازم نحط لها حاجه سبايسي
على واحد مسكرتك انا قلت منصور ستايل لانه
منصور وجعها قوي في حياتها فقمت جايبه
سلوجن منها بس برضه ما يبقاش مبتزا يعني
لا بس حلوه
خلينا نقول كمان على سره الباتع ما كنت
حتعمليه بالاساس كان انت مش موجوده في او
ما كنت حتنضمي لهم او كنت مشغوله
هو استاذ خالد يوسف مشكورا لما كلمني انا
كنت بحضر لمسلسل ليا اسمه كفر العميان هو
المسلسل ده اتاجل كان 30 حلقه وكنا شغالين
على السكريبت ولانه كان شويه في سحر
وشعوذه ففي جرافيكس قاعدين بنحضر له وازاي
ما يبقاش ساذج وبتاع
فعرض عليا المسلسل وما كانش لسه بعت لي
السكريبت ده كان من التليفون قلت له يعني
يشرفني وكل حاجه ان انا نفسي اعمل حاجه
البلدي بس يعني يا اما اعمل سر لباهته يا
اما اعمل مسلسلي فقال لي لا ما تقلقيش
هننسق قلت له ايوه انا معرفش ادخل الاثنين
في انون واحد كده وعايزه كل واحد قال لي
ما تقلقيش خالص
وشاء القدر ان انا فعلا دخلت السر وحضرته
وذاكرته ابتديت اصوره وكفر العميان ما
بيدخلش واجلت اجلت اجل ايه لان استاذ
ممدوح شاهين المنتج كلمني وقال لي بما انه
مسلسلك اتاج فانا محتاجك في 15 حلقه
تعيين فكر في فكره سريعه وندخل نعملها طيب
بس الناس وحتى يمكن خلينا في عندنا بوست
للمخرج خالد يوسف هو كان بيقول انه خلينا
نشوفه على الشاشه الان البوست اللي نزلوا
طبعا مخرج العمل خالد يوسف قال بوست في حب
احمد السعدني وحنان مطاوعه انا واقع في
غرام قصه حب صافيه والسلطان حامد منذ فكرت
فيها وكتبتها وعندما جسدتها وعندما جسدها
مثلا الحنان والسعدني وقعت في غرامها اكثر
يعني الناس طايحه في قصه الغرام
في حب كده يا حنان اه طبعا في اه طبعا اه
طبعا انا فرحانه جدا طبعا بالبوست ده انا
بعثت له على طول برده في حب الاستاذ خالد
وشيرت نفس المشهد اللي هو شيره
الحقيقه اذا كانت الشخصيه او الشخصيتين
سلطان حامد وصافيه طلعوا حلوين فده بسبب
استاذ خالد الحقيقه وسبب
ده ابو معانا والمساحه اللي اداها لنا ان
احنا نبدع فيها الحقيقه اذا كان هو في ناس
بتقول عليه ديكتاتور انا ما شفتش ده مع
الممثل انا كان مدينا هامش رائع حتى في
الارتجال في المشاهد في مشهد اللي احنا
بنجري واحنا اطفال وبيقطع علينا واحنا
كبار المشهد ده كان مكتوب ان احنا بنضحك
بس وكانت على
البيت اللي بيتهد وصباع حامد اللي بيطير
اقترحت على استاذ خالد ليه ما يبقاش فيه
ان انا بعلمه
القراءه والكتابه بشكل لذيذ وهو يعلمني
التحطيب لانها بنت قويه
فقال لي هتقولوا ايه فقام احمد قال طب ما
تيجي يعني احمد السعدني اقترح فكره انه
نقول
به تحت صحن تحتيه نقطه يبقى ايه
اللي هو البيه حرف الباء
وشكل البط هيبقى وارتجلناها فهو ضحك وقال
حبيتكم يلا صوروها مثلا بديكي مثال من قد
ايه هو كان بيخلينا نطلع ونختلق في
الشخصيه بما لا يتنافى مع رؤيته وفي
انسجام بينك وبين السعدني يعني احمد علاقه
قديمه يعني اصلا صحيح اه طبعا لا ده اخويا
احمد السعدني ده اخويا منذ الصغر انا
مستعجبه ان ده اول عمل لينا طبعا انا مش
انه اول عمل انا بالنسبه لي ده حماده
فكنت مرتاحه جدا وانا بشتغل معاه ده غير
ان هو فنان مبدع جدا
وملتزم جدا وخلوق جدا فكنت حاسه ان انا مع
اخويا في اللوكيشن حقيقي
وشفتي طبعا اكيد يعني اي عمل زي ما في
كمان كلام كويس في كمان بعض الانتقادات
بعض الناس قالوا انه رساله
المسلسل عن الهويه المصريه مباشره زياده
عن اللزوم وتتذكري وقت قاهره كابل برضو
قالوا نفس الشيء خصوصا كان بيلعب وقتها
الفنان الكبير طبعا نبيل الحلفاوي برضو
الدور فقالوا انه يعني في كلام مباشر وكذا
حسوا الناس بعض الشيء نفس الشيء في هذا
المسلسل بتحسي هذا الشيء ولا بتحسي انه لا
هو المفروض يكون مباشر
دايما هرد الرد اللي رديته وقت القاهره يا
ابو المدام الناس حست بكده يبقى الناس صح
انا دايما مع الراي الجامعي او الاغلبيه
لكن انا بشوف انه الفن وجهه نظر تتفق او
تختلفي معها كان من حق استاذ خالد يوسف
انه يختار اللغه دي للتخاطب مع الجمهور هو
اختار في الوقت ده في الحقبه دي يمكن
الشكل
المباشر لصحصحه
الضمير الجمعي او الاحساس بالوطنيه احيانا
انت بتبقي محتاجه ده احيانا بتبقي محتاجه
شكل مباشر يفوقك انك تحبي امك او انك تحبي
صديقتك او انك تحبي جيرانك احيانا انا مش
شايفه ان هو مباشر مش قادره اشوفها لكن لو
الناس شايفه كده فالناس على صواب انت
دائما متزنه كده
عشان احتاج اسجل معك كورسات لانه يعني انت
بتضحكيني يا ساره بس على فكره والله
العظيم لانه حتى لو سجلت معك كورسات برضو
في كل
ما بتزعلي احد
اخطاء مثلا حكايه انه الشوز الحديث اللي
ظهرت في المعارك والاشياء دي كلها هذه ايش
مثلا تحسي تحسي تصيد للعمل مثلا لما تكون
نتكلم والله انا شفت يعني شفت اعمال
عالميه ضخمه رائعه
للمخرجين عظماء كان فيها غلطه راكورات
الحقيقه يعني احنا عندنا كارثه اسمها
سوشيال ميديا انت ممكن تعملي
كلوسب على لحظه تقعدي تعملي زوم زوم زوم
زوم زووم
انا شفت بعيني 500 كومبارس 500 جندي
بيدار وفي مشاهد يا مثلا مشهد محاكمه
السلطان حامد محاكمه السلطان حامد دي
اتعملت في اربع ايام مشهد يعني احنا بنعمل
دلوقتي في الصناعه كان جامعكم كلكم كلكم
احنا دلوقتي في المسلسلات بنعمل بالعشرين
مشهد في اليوم فان احنا نقعد في مشهد اربع
ايام عايزه اقول لك الاتقان بس وارد قوي
انه يبقى واحد من الكومبارسات رجله وجعته
واحنا بنصور 12 ساعه والدنيا بارده او
الدنيا شمس على حسب
في يوم قام قلع الجزمه ولبس جزمه ثانيه
حقيقي ممكن يبقى محدش خد باله انها يعني
حقيقي في اخطاء لو حد جه معانا اللوكيشن
وشاف الدنيا بيت ودار ازاي هيعرف انه انك
تعملي كنترول طول الوقت صعب لكن
حتى لو في اخطاء ما دام الناس شافت ان في
اخطاء يبقى في اخطاء بس في ايجابيات كمان
في عمل كبير انا مش معقوله ابقى بصه لك
اقول لك معلش الشعرايه دي طالعه وما اشوفش
قد ايه انت جميله في كل حاجه في لباقتك في
كلامك فاتمنى
مش مثال بس من حنانه ده حنان بتقصده معايا
ايوه انا بقصده انا بقصد وصل وقتنا
للنهايه للاسف انا بشكرك جدا على وجودك
معانا اليوم نورتيني نورتينا نورتينا وانت
عارفه على المستوى الشخصي قد ايش احبك
كانت معنى النجمه حنان المطاوع